ce
[Musique]
soir les enfants dont les vols l'europe
un instant nounours à temps il faut que
je te parle d'une lettre que je viens de
recevoir elle arrive decosse c'est un
petit garçon et c'est une petite fille
qui m'écrivent le loup et lili de cross
c'est loin pas trop vu profs non ce
n'est pas très loin nous devrions aller
y faire un tour loulou et les lits nous
demande de venir d'urgence au nil ont un
petit frère qui s'appelle baby et qui
pleure si fort la nuit qui les empêche
de dormir tiens oh oui allons-y pour
relouer ligne c'est un vilain ce papy je
vais m'occuper de lui je descend vite
embrasser nicolas et pimprenelle
ensuite en route pour les gosses et hop
hop hop hop
[Musique]
bravo c'est très joli vous avez fait des
progrès c'est une lettre ne t'apporte
maintenant non c'est la lettre de deux
petits enfants etc au sein
loulou elie nous disent que leur petit
frère baby n'arrête pas de pleurer
toutes les nuits
non aussi nous allons faire un petit
voyage en écosse pour nous occuper un
peu de ce papy mais non il faut surtout
pas gondé akébé s'il pleure c'était
parce qu'il a foi tient qu'elle
apportera cette couverture du lait
moi je crois qu'il a surtout besoin
d'une bonne fessée tu crois nicolas
nicolas je vais voir ça de près tiens
nous aussi
[Musique]
merci pas preneur tu es le vrai petit
môme bon
je vais chercher autre chose
si avec les bébés
merci pas preneur mais je crois que je
suis assez chargé comme ça
c'est affreux qu'est ce qu'il y en a
encore calé pas tout toute seule il faut
lé là vient vous allez voir un bébé je
voulais la vraie en arrivant là bas
c'est promis dès que j'arriverai chez
loulou il
alors il est pas ouais on a compris
au lit
elle ne faut pas tellement sale mais pas
tout
dit dans nos tu m'as pas t'occuper tout
le temps de se bat bien mais classe et
non je vais visiter les musées
alain thorelle nous acheter des cadeaux
oui mais à une condition
vous me promettez y est d'aller au lit
de bonheur tous les soirs
et sans rouspéter nicolas
feuz n'oublie pas ton panier et embrasse
baby de ma part on dit aussi beaux jours
à l'eau et lee oui je n'oublierai pas la
jette à l'honneur
bonne nuit des enfants
à bien tous à bientôt mme enos faites un
bon voyage bon voyage
[Musique]
te voilà bien chargé nounours ce sont
des cadeaux pour baby on n'y va pas trop
oui les vins sont bons en route pour les
cosses mon bon nounours en route pour
les cross à bientôt les enfants à
bientôt
bonne nuit
[Musique]